from protesters to police officers
appeared to be shifting strategy today
as police worked to clear the remaining
protesters from the area the slow
methodical approach that we saw from
police yesterday seemed to be replaced
with a much tougher line today our auto
bureau chief mercedes stephenson has
been on the ground today so mercedes
what did you make of the police tactics
you saw today
jeff it felt very different from
yesterday where things started out very
slowly the officers who were on the
front line yesterday were just in their
regular uniforms they didn't have
additional body armor helmets on today
it was clear there was a different tone
being set the officers who came out
were wearing riot gear they were on the
front lines and they were carrying large
wooden batons with them which they were
using to strike people if they didn't
move back when the police line moved
forward they also had gas masks in some
cases and eventually the line that i got
pushed back by
on a side street here had full-blown gas
masks under riot helmets which led
people to believe they were going to be
gassed that never happened by the way
despite social media reports about it
there was a much faster pace that was
undertaken by the officers
it was more aggressive and there was a
harder element right behind them the
emergency response team who are tactical
officers with the rcmp very elite unit
were being used to clear out the tents
and also being used to clear out the
trucks and they had their weapons out
and drawn i did not see them pointing
them at anybody but it certainly was a
much more aggressive presence and it was
much more rapid they cleared all of
wellington street in the side streets in
a day in something that experts thought
might take as long as a week to do
yeah we heard the statement from the
police chief earlier citing concerns
about misinformation disinformation
circulating on social media how would
you describe you know what you're seeing
online versus the reality there on the
ground
yeah there were some people alleging
police brutality i didn't see that i did
see people absolutely getting hit by
batons and some rough arrests those were
people who did not move back as the
police line advanced sometimes they were
on their knees
begging with officers some veterans
saying please don't do this but if you
did not move when they told you to move
that was the fate that you suffered
there was no gas used nobody was shot
there was not mass arrests at gun points
despite what a new york times headline
appeared to report and most importantly
no one died because there was a false
report on american news that a woman was
trampled by a horse yesterday that did
not happen that was confirmed by both
police and ems but the police chief did
talk today about the problem they've had
with misinformation and disinformation
this is what he had to say one of the
tactics that the protesters and
demonstrators are using is
misinformation
information that is inaccurate
information that misleads the public
we're actively tweeting and providing
information out in through social media
and other media
mechanisms in order to be able to try
and get accurate factual information
around what is going on within the
protest
so jeff certainly a more aggressive
police presence and the possibility you
could get hurt if you did not move back
when the police instructed you to but
nothing like some of the other riot
police i've seen in action in the past
including at the g7 g20 which was much
more aggressive tactics
mercedes-stevenson in ottawa thanks
mercedes